to dust that is a
a manipulator move and it doesn't change
the fact that he's not necessarily
enough that's women
to take the easy way out
men just are homeless
if a man has no opportunity he's just
homeless
or women they get to use that if they
want to and then they take the easy way
out
and then like they're not being
manipulated if they make a choice go
ahead i mean
you're saying the easy way out like i'm
not going to sit here and
defend
all the points but it's one thing just
so just record it yeah that's all we
keep going it's one thing to say the
easy route but i think there's a there's
an element of survival instinct that
goes in there and it's it's one thing i
think what she's speaking about is not
just like oh i want to be a millionaire
tomorrow
i'll do that it's more of like a
and correct me from wrong corr it's more
of like a if i don't do this i'll be
homeless and you're saying men will go
and be homeless and that's fair or
they'll get a job which is fair but i'm
i'm assuming what she's speaking about
is like as opposed to being homeless
this is an option i have that i won't
that's so why yeah so you get an
opportunity yeah and so i'm saying like
how are they being manipulated if you're
being given an opportunity like because
i i kind of think of
from my point of view like i run youtube
channels and so i know how much work
goes behind like making money off of a
youtube channel on the back end so he's
just doing that with only fans work and
so where he knows the back end he knows
what to say he knows how to make money
he knows the business and if the girl
wants to take the opportunity she can or
she can
like like that i kind of do something
similar it's like if you want to go
build it on your own good luck but
compare that to kind of the music
industry and a lot of the how artists
came in like you know usher and all
those were like 17 16 when they started
then eventually they were 18 they signed
this contract and from my perspective
mike's becksburg opinion i guess um a
lot of these contracts aren't in their
favor and they don't know that um and so
in those situations it's one thing to
say okay like we didn't manipulate them
they signed this contract
but there is a predatory and i don't
want to use
there's like an element of predatory
nature that goes into that like here's a
contract we drafted it it's in our favor
you'll write one song and sing it and
become famous but we own all your
masters da da i think it's kind of in
that same vein not i mean well i think
it's just more like than do it on your
own
i mean like it's just it's just someone
has lev every deal someone has leverage
there's a million people that want to be
famous there's only a couple music
companies so if you have leverage you
get a better deal so now the question is
yes it's a leverage thing the people who
take advantage of that leverage to like
an extreme
point are they not bad people and the
people who
have less leverage and
and who have less leverage and are taken
advantage of or they like they're not
well i don't think it's i think it's you
take what you're worth
so
if you could get a better deal elsewhere
you wouldn't take it that's true
otherwise go go somewhere else go start
it on your own they don't want to do
that
i was going to say would you have the
same idea if a lady suggested to do it
on her own so she's out there doing not
knowing she's tricking finessing
whatever you call it is that good
business or is that manipulation well i
have my own opinions on all that the
whole system and that whole
well but um i think if she does it on
our own that's that's one thing but it's
it's another thing to like i can
appreciate that they're people in
hard situations where it's like here is
an opportunity and you will take that
opportunity more so than anyone else
like the average person and those are
quote-unquote vulnerable people that'll
do xyz so and i don't think they're
vulnerable i think they're lazy
i mean you could talk to men on the
internet and take your clothes off or
you could go work at mcdonald's and they
said um i'll give i'll give you an
example i'll give an example let's let's
use it in a more professional setting
let's say you you know you went to
school spent hundreds of thousand
dollars to get a degree
and now you have debt and now you have
to take like you know you apply for jobs
the one job that gives you an
opportunity is a job that pays pretty
trash
and you know they have some very like
you know the terms aren't amazing but
it's the only job you got you have debt
and if you don't do that your options to
be homeless or to take this job i think
you
would agree with me if i if you said um
if someone said like
you know i'm not gonna take that job i'm
just going to go be homeless you look at
that person be like no you're being lazy
take the job do
would you agree with me on that because
in the same vein
if that person takes the job and now
they're in a you know a shitty place a
shitty deal i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't
i wouldn't call them
lazy if they chose not to take an only
fan's job
if they chose so because i think that's
the comparison you're trying to make but
i i would say just don't like there are
consequences for every decision i
wouldn't say you're being manipulated
but i mean like things can be right you
can be manipulated how are you being
manipulated if you you really chose to
take a job i think manipulation has a
negative context but it's not it doesn't
necessarily have to be like if if i walk
into the room and i'm wearing like a
cologne and everyone likes the cologne
and i'm like oh by the way buy this
cologne
that's a manipulation in a sense it
doesn't have to be like a white it's
advertising but baptizing is
manipulation you're manipulating he's
right
we see it in a negative context but it
doesn't have to be i think manipulation
well i'm talking about how she was
describing it it seemed negative yeah
she did like because we're kind of like
changing the goal post a little bit go
ahead
i'm going someone who's speaking with me
oh sorry i thought one of you were
saying something i was you um i wanted
to respond to that if if you choose to
go into sex work
understand that there are certain
consequences that you have to deal with
but like andrew tate said he likes to be
in romania because he can pay off the
police which makes you ask why would you
want to pay off the police if everything
you're doing is legit and it's like with
the stories of these girls comparing it
like saying how it's so hard to leave
because he even scares these girls into
not leaving and uses his power and fame
against these girls what are these girls
in romania going to do do you have like
what clip are you talking about because
we could pull it up um basically i just
like watching how some people just
gather up their research and collective
there's a let me oh i can just yeah
it's fine you can you can grab your
phone
um and then blessing can pull it up or
if you um if you send it to me on
instagram i'll put it in the dark so
blessing can use it is that the one
where he was he mentioned about um it's
like the grape associated one where he's
like oh i'm not saying i'm a rapist but
i like to be in countries where i can do
whatever i want is that yeah that's the
that's the snippet of him but in terms
of the people who've released this
information about um andrew tate but
then again it could be false so i'm just
saying that
usually like i mean if you think about
the statement and then the allegations i
just think there's there has to be some
sort of connect but then again
i just think like you have to be proven
guilty of something
like i don't like being in a society
where we can like you can be proven
guilty without going to court i agree
with that to a certain extent you know
that i think it's so much better if you
can have substantial evidence behind
something before you can make those
accusations i think what's very
problematic about this case is that
there's a lot of
smoke
so you have to kind of question is there
a fire behind it if there's multiple
clips coming out with multiple
allegations and multiple like yes we
made a point about like click bait and
you know certain things might be said
for entertainment purposes but when
there's that much smoke i'm a bit
curious well i don't know because one of
the so i was doing the interviews and
one of the common things that people
were saying is there was that clip of
that girl getting like
um
they said she was being abused on camera
um but then she came forward and said no
that was a yeah you know that was a sex
play that's actually one of the clips i
have for us to watch but then i guess
the same the same uh thing that we would
apply to is that true or not you could
say the same thing for her it's true
because they're already feeling
manipulated does she have to retract it
because just as she was saying before
when someone's a massive superpower has
a lot of money and a lot of influence
behind them
people retract their statements a lot
when there's such things as saying
really i'd say they're more i would say
girls come out more when someone has
power money and fame i mean how many
girls have come forward and had great
accusations against men just to be
proven they're lying because they
empower money and fame yeah and how many
girls have never even come forward at
all because they're so petrified i mean
i would i wouldn't go that far because
there has to be evidence
like there's not there's not evidence if
you won't go to court and press charges
yeah you can't say there's there's you
can't say so you can't say oh there's
all these girls that don't come forward
if we don't have evidence yeah you're
just you're just like assuming you're
assuming they're telling the truth no
you make a really good point there that
there isn't evidence in court but that
doesn't mean there's no evidence of
their experience exactly but you have to
investigate you have to investigate
claims and so even even in this case
like i think oftentimes like we have
this default where we want to defend
women at all costs and you're kind of
doing it because even when she says the
words out of my mouth are um i this was
a sex play this was just play you're
still trying to like paint him as the
bad guy no it's interesting because you
said i'm trying to defend women at all
costs
and this particular case is pertaining
to women if it was to do with a man my
stance would be exactly the same and i
think there's something to be said as
well there's physical abuse but we can't
forget there is mental abuse and that's
something that does happen and you have
to remember that yes although some women
have consented in that moment but there
is a big element of mental abuse that
does happen to men and women and i do
think again what is mental abuse mental
abuse comes in i'm not gonna go no but
in order to accuse someone of something
you have to i didn't i didn't say